[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meine taten
heute gibt es von mir ein leckere suppen
rezept dieser hackfleisch lauchsuppe
mache ich sehr gerne und sehr häufig
wenn ihr also wissen wollte wie man die
suppe herrscht sind dann bleibt jetzt
dran jetzt folgen nämlich zuerst einmal
die zutaten an zutaten braucht ihr etwa
300 gramm hackfleisch das ist jetzt
hinter hackfleisch dass ich noch ein
bisschen gefroren aber man kann es ja
ich weiter verwenden
ihr braucht 1 2 stangen lauch ich habe
mal zwei genommen ich habe nämlich das
dunkelgrüne schon im supermarkt entfernt
eine große zwiebel 200 gramm schlagsahne
eins bis zwei esslöffel frischkäse creme
fraiche oder schmand oder saurer um
irgendwie so in der richtung etwas zwei
große kartoffel 600 milliliter
gemüsebrühe ich nehme dafür einfach 600
milliliter wasser und zweifel für
gemüsebrühe die von alnatura und etwas
pfeffer und das war's dann auch schon
bevor es an die zubereitung das super
geht muss erst einmal das gemüse geputzt
werden und vorbereitet werden und wie
das geht den nächsten schritt die
zutaten stelle ich so lange auf die
seite und kümmere mich so lange um das
gemüse dazu zähle ich jetzt erst einmal
die zwiebel ich hab euch mal in meinem
video gezeigt wie man zwiebeln richtig
schneidet ich glaube es war in dem küste
videos mit dem rücken salat
als ich hier oben schön die wurzel dran
lassen und den strengen hier wächst
[Musik]
fliegen und halbieren und dann habt ihr
hier oben die wurzel die die ganze
zwiebel zusammenhält und jetzt schneidet
ihr mit dem messer kleine würfel zuerst
längst aber nicht bis ganz durch mit die
zwiebel nicht auseinanderfällt schöne
kleine würfel und dann wird es einmal
gedreht
jetzt könnt ihr den krallen griff machen
und die würfel unterscheiden und so
fällt euch den hebel nicht auseinander
und er schneidet euch nicht in die
finger und das letzte stück schmeiße ich
[Musik]
jetzt kümmere ich mich um den lauf mit
laufe ich das ja immer so eine sache der
stadt ziemlich dreckig ich nehme
deswegen zuerst einmal die äußere schale
weg die eine steht hier unten die
wurzeln ab und hier schneide ich mir das
dunkelgrüne werk das sich nämlich
ziemlich bitte das solltet ihr auch
immer darauf achten immer schöne
hellgrüne stange zu kaufen
und weil der sich so nicht gut waschen
lässt halte ich den jetzt einmal
längst durch dann kann ich den aufmachen
und hier schön drin waschen können da
wirklich unterm wasserhahn das dann
schön aufmachen und durch waschen das
mache ich mal kurz und zeigt euch dann
das ergebnis nach dem waschen sieht das
dann so aus
und jetzt kann ich trete und jetzt kann
ich hier schönheit bringe unterscheiden
so etwa ein halber zentimeter dick die
stange lauch fertig und da kann ich mich
um die kartoffel kümmern
die kartoffeln werden einfach geschält
und wenn zuträglich sind und auch noch
gewaschen
also ich war eigentlich immer nach dem
schälen
[Musik]
schneide ich das schreiben und danach in
würfel dieser ersten paar scheiben dann
flach legen andere scheiben runter
schneiden dann längst in stifte
schneiden in würfel
die sollten so etwa ein halber meter
groß sein
[Musik]
in etwa so aussehen und jetzt zeige ich
euch wie man das gemüse
weiterverarbeitet für die suppe nehmt
ihr euch am besten in großen suppentopf
ich habe vor allem vergessen zu erwähnen
dass ihr auch noch öl braucht ich habe
etwa zwei esslöffel öl tritt das ist
geschmacksneutrale sonnenblumenöl da
gebe ich jetzt mein hackfleisch rein die
der topf ist schon heiß auf höchster
stufe
es ist schön an noch mit starkem 1 hat
vielleicht noch besorgen es macht dich
aber nicht
es ist dieser woche auf fleisch das vor
aktiv gekühlt war im kühlschrank
auftauen lässt aber wenn es mal schnell
gehen muss da macht es einfach so das
macht sinn wenn du sagst fall schon
anfängt zu knistern kommen die zwiebeln
getragen und werde angelastet
etwa drei bis vier minuten mit anbraten
das ist das gute aroma entwickeln kann
[Musik]
das ist grundsätzlich kommt jetzt der
lauf mit rein und den lassen wir jetzt
auch noch mal ein paar minuten mittel
gefordert dann abgelöscht wird
[Musik]
sie ist auch dass der auch etwas
zusammengefallen ist
und wenn es dann so weit ist wird es mit
der gemüsebrühe abgelöscht
in meinem fall dann eben mit dem wasser
und mit den zwei prüfen
[Musik]
kochen wenn die suppe dann kocht kommen
jetzt noch die kartoffeln mit rein und
dann musst du bist so lange kochen bis
die kartoffeln weich sind
das wird so etwa 20 minuten dauern
die einfach wieder deckel drauf und 20
minuten köcheln lassen
wenn die kartoffeln dann weich sind gibt
ihr die sahne zur soko mitte wo davide
aufpassen und nicht mehr kochen lassen
und kurz durchrühren dann kommt da noch
frischkäse rein oder eben sahne oder
crème fraiche oder schmand könnt ihr im
prinzip auch weglassen aber ich finde es
gibt dann noch mal leicht säuerlichen
geschmack dann noch etwas kälter mit
zahlt für dich eher sparsam arbeiten
weil er gebetet
aber ich glaube hier brauche ich jetzt
auch noch eine prise und muss tatenlos
schmeckt einfach ziemlich gut und noch
mit früheren und abschmecken und stellt
eure suche auch schon fertig also ich
bin die suppe so ganz gut mit den
stückchen wem sie zu flüssig ist kann da
auch noch mit meda damit stärker binden
oder anteil der suppe pürieren
aber ich finde so eigentlich nicht
schlimm und danach könnt ihr die suppe
dann einfach servieren und genießen ich
hoffe dieses rezept gefällt euch und er
kocht es nach ich wünsche euch auf jeden
fall viel spaß beim nachkochen wünsche
euch einen guten appetit und dann sehen
wir uns bereits zum nächsten video das
wird ein muttertags video mit einer
leckeren etwa torte und da freue ich
mich schon ganz besonders drauf die bin
ich nämlich gerade noch am baum sehen
wir uns die wochen auf jeden fall noch
einmal und dann bis bald
[Musik]